I don't love you anymore I really am
sorry Jules what about all the plans we
have coming up Lake Tahoe in December I
mean it's my company's retreat
Ramona's wedding this spring you mean
Ramona my sister should I be aware of
anything else in my life that completely
revolves around you that's my sweatshirt
but I don't need you I don't know what
to do now boyfriend I'm out together
every day Bert a decade now things are
getting weird why have you never seen an
old cat lady before if you're here it
means you need some help getting back
that's spending time with other women
your personal relationships have all
expired are you think I don't have any
friends you have no friends I'm the
Prince I'll be just taking a second to
load don't touch my property was so
caught up in my relationship that I
abandoned entire gender' of friendships
oh my god Jeremy broke up with you
that's crazy I'm here to see you Jeremy
broke up with me I want us all to be
friends again we've got a lot to teach
you I'm not letting you miss girls night
out will not be a buzzkill level mom EFS
California you are charged with
murdering the buzz in the first degree
he's moved on so should you what you
need right now is a hot guy so you can
hook up with them they'll never actually
date him you look like someone who's
ready to take home the man of her dreams
seems great for Reba Oh our gentlemen in
the showroom aren't available for a
short-term lease five all these are as
is ready to go home tonight my spare
time I really love to play with Legos
[Music]
dude Ben Moe I'm so van mowing you
you've really been putting the effort to
be a functioning woman with actual
friends who are not her cat like I have
been doing amazing at being a girl no
one said that for me amazing for me I
accidently liked my ex-boyfriends new
girlfriend Instagram where is it how
long ago did you like it 30 seconds
she's seen it BAM
we're gonna need you to step inside
[Music]
you